guess who's here it's supersaf from
supersaf tv this is so much fun so
welcome to los angeles the day that you
got here it
was an awful downpour i'm sorry you
brought it sorry it just follows me
wherever i go the uk what when they just
follow me
i can't believe it but today we're doing
something really fun i originally told
you that we were gonna do a gift guide
but then i forgot what i told you i've
got just some stuff here
sitting on my desk these are a few of my
favorite things a few of your favorite
things
we should just start my top favorite
thing this year has been
the new apple watch oh yeah i am
obsessed the watch os five i've
loved doing the competitions like i have
become so
disgustingly obsessed with this apple
watch and competing against my friends
and fitness activities
that i think i've lost all my friends
i've seen them like pop up on twitter
like where you just like
with jenna and marquez it's just like i
wish i was part of that but i don't have
an apple watch i'm sorry it's okay you
have another watch
this is my favorite smartwatch which is
the samsung galaxy watch
i primarily use android we're still
friends though which is which is cool
right so
uh but i i
no i did not give an answer but i mean
what i love about it is the
rotating bezel like i just think that's
the easiest way to navigate on
smartwatch and it's also got great
battery life i'm easily getting three
days sometimes four days
and i don't like charging something else
for
yeah three or four days yeah which is
really cool because i have so many
smartphones to charge and then it's like
because this is like three days i just
don't have to worry about it i will say
that battery life is pretty good i mean
i get pretty much a full day with this
but
which is it's not bad but then you have
to charge it every night right i mean i
charge my phone every night yeah so you
know i have an apple watch
and phone charging dock station so
yeah maybe i need to get one of those
maybe you do but it's okay yeah you
gotta get one so we can compete
well marquez he burns like a thousand
calories in before noon and i'm like
what are you doing
yeah well he does ultimate frisbee right
next up about some
phones there was a lot of phones that
came out this year there is a lot what
was your favorite well there's a few
favorites but one of the ones that i'm
using right now
especially because i'm traveling uh is
the huawei mate 20 pro
this is the first time i'm seeing it in
person in this beautiful twilight
wow can i touch it if you like
and i think the best thing about this is
the battery life yeah it just
it's the best battery life that i've
used on a smartphone you'll see them so
right now i'm out here in la and i can
have my home sim i can also have a sing
here
the triple cameras the ultra wide is so
awesome yeah like i love the ultra rifle
a lot of things well obviously you guys
know i'm a huge iphone fan and there
were so
many phones that came out this year for
the iphone we had the iphone 10s
the 10s max and of course the 10r which
i thought the 10r was great i think for
what it is
it's a pretty great phone but my go-to
is i'm not going to tell you because
it's
going to be in a video oh your channel
one of these
ones guess which one it is take a pic
phones done next up we've got some
tablets here
we do it's been a good year for tablets
as well it has been there's been a lot
of fun stuff so obviously the ipad pro
is beyond incredible like it has made me
love using the ipad again it is it's
really good and i'm somebody who uses um
a pen
a lot even when i'm editing on the pc
and stuff so having the apple pencil
it's just something that's really cool
for me when you edit with a
pen do edit with a pen and you add it on
a pc
i how did i let you in the door there is
a
metal detector that's like it's a pc
android detector
talking about android and pc and adobe
premiere pro
this is adobe rush oh yeah they did a
really great job on the app
there's but i don't understand why they
not allow you to speed up footage
they need to do that hopefully i mean
it's it's new yeah so i've had pro
ipad pro yeah just super fast uh i mean
it's it's i've been using procreate just
to kind of do some doodling i used to do
that a lot before as well
so it's kind of got me back in with that
side of like being a little bit more
creative yeah it's really cool like 120
hats refresh rate it's just
you you actually notice it coming from
something else
it is really good speaking of something
else this is actually another thing that
i've been really liking is the microsoft
surface go
it's just it's so small it's so compact
it's portable
and it's black it is the matte black the
matte black just looks so good and so
good
as you may have been able to tell i i
really like the color black so
me too actually so yeah yeah it kind of
nice with the contrast the white it does
yeah but like the matte black is
incredible
i mean i love the stylus and i just
really do love that
i can actually play fortnite on this
yeah which was kind of shocking to me
not
incredibly well yeah but it still ran
for tonight it is pretty cool i
do like microsoft's hardware just how
everything's built everything they're
doing with the surface like they just
look really good
they do surface studio oh my gosh oh i
need to try to try that
it's beautiful do you want to bring it
over here that might be a little
aggressive
it's over at my desk right now it's a
surface studio i i love
everything they're doing with surface so
i made a huge iphone fan girl but i'm
also an xbox
and studio girl too so let's not forget
it's good to have a balance isn't it it
is yeah what else do we have
so we have um earphones i love the
airpods but they don't stay in my ears i
don't like weirdly shaped ears so i need
something that actually stays in so i've
been using the gear icon x oh i haven't
had 2018
yeah so what i really like about these
is they stay in my ear because of this
little hook
and they have storage built in so you've
got four gigabytes
built into the earphones themselves so
if you don't have your phone with you
you can still have some music playing on
your phone i don't think everybody likes
them but yeah
yeah i like that but as long as you like
them that's okay
but speaking of headphones there's
another pair of headphones that came out
this year actually
not too long ago they're the dolby
dimension headphones
so you can connect three different
things to them and you just compress the
button and they're super soft
what i like about this is it has this
thing called life mix what's your
favorite song what's my favorite song
like what's your favorite band
i'm i just listen to anything that
sounds good okay do you like heavy metal
i don't mind okay one thing that i think
we do have in common is that i always
listen to
scented versions of songs like yes i
don't know anybody else who did that
because when you tweeted i was like
finally somebody else one of the person
in the world that does that i do because
it's
so aggressive this is a nice little song
okay so here you go
okay cool okay it's cool it sounds nice
huh no idea
okay i literally got here look at what
the
okay
now can you hear me now i can hear you
pretty clearly right
i can hear you more clearly than like
normal i
it's so weird to this microphone it's
pretty cool isn't it cool yeah the first
time i i've like
actually experienced this like fell on
the floor that was so cool like so if
you need to hear
what's going on around you and oh i can
hear you oh it's so shocking
it is it's so weird it is it is quite
weird like the because
it's like picking it up from the mics
and then playing it back over the music
so it's like that's exactly what it's
doing
awesome i need to get me a pair of those
it's pretty cool headphones check
what about uh what else uh what have you
been storing your i'm baiting you right
now
so what have you been throwing your
files on lately i've been using the t5
the samsung t5
which i absolutely love but i know
you've got the newer version with
thunderbolt 3 right i held off
until i was like why this is basically
like my whole life revolves around
editing and
the faster you can transfer footage or
you can edit the more i can get done so
this is the x5
the only downside is it is really
expensive i think
with these things that will come down in
price over time only two terabytes which
is also sort of a problem because i feel
like you know we're shooting at 4k
and all this high-res stuff and it just
it eats away super quick
it does and it's funny how you said only
two terabytes which
you know for a lot of people will be
like only two terabytes
when you're editing 4k footage i mean
this probably has three project files on
it
and that's like that's it now we're
gonna go on to some cameras
there's been so many smaller cameras
lately and
this is probably my favorite this just
recently came out oh i've not even had a
chance this is the first time i've seen
it this is the first time i'm seeing it
it's really quite exciting
arsenal pocket that is that is cool that
is small
so small what's great is you can just
plug it right into your phone too
awesome so it's got a lightning that
that can change right too yeah so it can
be a usb-c
or micro usb and you adjust and then the
app pops up
like this is it oh wow hey hey who's
this guy
how did how did you get in here
you're like i came here to help with
camera stuff but it's all automated it
just does itself
she's already got it all sorted awesome
like it's so
smooth this is really cool and speaking
of dji
obviously they're known for their drones
of course two really great drones this
year the mavic pro and the mavic pro
zoom
yeah having that zoom does there's so
many use cases like if you're
trying to do something but you can't get
too close like if there's wildlife
that's
going to run away or something you can
use that zoom the dolly zoom
like that's so awesome that just gives
you so much more scope
when you're out filming just recently i
took a ford raptor out in the desert and
went off-roading and this is
the most fun that i've had ever and the
tracking was so incredible
most of these shots i took right here
i'll show you guys these were mostly
shot with the pro
[Music]
all right you guys want to go for a ride
all right so we'll see you later
let's go we wanted to go fast but we're
in la traffic
we have like bursts of fast and then we
have to slow down to venice right
i don't know sure this
this yeah we're in the raptor with
excuse me why would you pull out in
front of me you should have brought that
can you not see
361x i actually use this in the desert
too and this one actually just came out
this is the
apple version so this is the one that
they have at the apple stores but this
thing
is amazing like i have been using the
insta360 one x the first version i sold
that yeah
it was the insta360 one this is the
insta 360 one x
one x not 10. the x is just getting
confusing isn't it i can't handle it i
wonder what the next iphone is gonna be
called
we can't i can't think about that yet
i'm so i'm still recovering from iphone
mania this past few months but this
thing's great so this does 360
all the way around but it's really cool
because you can do sort of like the
gopro
did like the over capture let's just
should we just unbox it right now
let's do it can we get some knives
please here's the knife man
let's see what should we show you what
should we drive today
[Laughter]
may i recommend the purple
particularly good today this is a bread
knife everybody needs a knife man
well let's not use the brick this one's
not that good we'll use it no we'll go
let's go let's fight him
you have one job come on look at this
this is a great beautiful mountain that
is
pretty cool okay all right oh
that i'm pretty impressed with that
precision
just when i said that just when i said
that
like i need to get a new desk because i
have like jams
yeah i have that problem this is the
problem with the white desk as well yeah
that's cool
okay okay it's really suctioned in there
how many youtubers did it take to open a
box
i don't know we're supposed to be good
at this we're supposed to be
professionals just seeing what we do
this has a new tripod too i should put
the knife away yeah
that's a good idea i'm super hyped
because the one that i had before only
had one battery
it didn't have this nice tripod cool wow
wow so this is the apple store bundle
this is actually
super nice this is a bullet time stick
oh
so it does bullet time yes you swing it
around your head
is that safe well i mean you need to be
aware of your surroundings
you just like
um that goes into the camera and then it
goes right into your phone
cool and there's even one for you oh
thank you
for your little not iphone but not
iphones and for iphones there you go
so yeah that's the insta360 one x it's
incredible you definitely have to check
it out i think that you have so much
awesome
let's stick this outside the ford raptor
[Music]
let's go
did we talk about all the things i think
that's everything isn't it have you
forgotten anything
so this right here this is the a7 3 that
came out this year and it's
been my go-to camera come here let's
let's chat about it
this is just my chase here we go hey
there it is no wait do you want to talk
about it
it's beautiful it really is beautiful
the auto focus
nice one yeah it's your recommendation
actually i'm an enabler you are an
enabler so david actually
shot one of my videos with this i looked
absolutely awesome and i'm like sold i
want to buy it
but it doesn't have a phillips screen
that's the only thing that's my only
criticism
trust me it's everyone's criticism i
mean
it comes out this much it can't be that
hard to flip it all over i
know it can't be wrong i don't
understand sony please do it
and take my money i will literally throw
my money at you
if you give me one of these with the
flip out you thank you david you're
welcome yeah
you shouldn't keep him here you can look
after maddie and just bring stuff right
the dog loves you and he's like you
can't ever leave me
well this is some of our favorite tech
of 2018
i'm so excited for next year are you
going to ces this year
um i think i will be yeah you'll be
there yes
i will we'll meet up at the dji booth
again see you there it'll be fun
well thank you guys so much for watching
be sure to go check out his channel and
subscribe i'll put all the links in the
description
and i feel like annotations are not what
they they're gone now
yeah we still have the cards i haven't
used an annotation in a really long time
anyway
so it's okay they don't work on mobile
anyway and most people
watch videos on mobile so well thanks
for watching
let us know also in the comments below
what your favorite tech is of 2018.
thanks for having me yes thank you
so awesome to be in the channel and here
thank you i can't believe you're here
yeah finally this is weird this is
awesome it's like it's like
the opposite side of the world it is and
i bought the weather along with me you
did just for you to see but at least i
have a white wall so you feel at home so
it's like actually yeah it's pretty
similar
it's great yeah awesome thanks for
having me and we're gonna be having
justine on the channel as well
[Music]